well joining us now is George Eustace
who until Thursday was the Minister for
agriculture fisheries and food so thank
you very much you're going come on the
show feels like the right week too happy
for many reasons we were just hearing
there some of the concerns for from
farmers the people that I speak to we're
very worried about the lack of clarity
they're also very worried about no deal
and they're not alone I mean we can just
have a look now at something that the
current president at the National
Farmers Union said on this show this is
huge for every single person and it's
not understood what no dual means it
will be absolutely savage for us I mean
a farm us right to be this worried
no they're wrong I mean it would be
difficult there would be some turbulence
but we've done huge amounts of planning
for this event reality so the truth is
we've already agreed that we all have
tariff rate suspensions on goods that we
don't produce things like citrus so that
we can keep prices stable but we will
also put in place tariffs to protect
some of those sensitive sectors
including beef including sheep and
possibly some of the dairy sectors as
well and we've also done a great deal of
work in terms of how we can continue to
get our exports into the European Union
making sure we've got the IT in place to
do export health certificates having
some discussions with for instance
authorities in Calais and French about
how they would handle customs checks and
border inspection posts so I mean you've
been in this for months and months and
months you know what's happening behind
the scenes when perhaps we on the
outside don't have that clarity so we're
our food price is going to go up or down
do we know we will be aiming through our
tariff policy to keep three prices
stable and but the truth is the biggest
impacts on food prices will be exchange
rates and if for instance there was say
a 10 percent devaluation in sterling
well that might increase food prices by
about two and a half percent but just to
put it into context food prices go up or
down by five to ten percent in any
typical year so it's a relatively small
jolt but it is nevertheless a jolt and
that's why we obviously want an
agreement that's preferable and I'll be
voting for the prime minister's
agreement when it returns to the house
but we mustn't be fearful of leaving
without an agreement if we can't get an
agreement in place the truth is the
British civil service have done a
sterling job in
terms of making sure we are ready to
leave we're good to go if Parliament has
the courage to decide again okay now you
just said that and that when you already
which is that you're going to vote for
Teresa maids do so what I don't quite
understand is why did you resign if you
can a vote for her deal anyway well you
know always in politics there's a
question of where you can have most
influence and as a general rule that's
staying within government to try to
influence policy and you know I've stuck
with the government through a lot of
undignified retreats over the last
couple of years but what happened last
week I think was fundamentally different
because what effectively happened is
that the government was taken hostage
and some cabinet members in government
colluded in that hostage taking so you
have to ask the question is it any
longer worthwhile being in that
government when we have weeks to go the
biggest decision this country's faced
for half a century
so who take the government hostage well
there were a parliament s and very
clearly so and some members of the
cabinet was saying as well there were
main supporting sometimes the cabinet
were clear the parliament had to have a
vote that word as they put it take no
deal off the table as soon as you take
no deal off the table you dramatically
undermine your credibility as a country
you undermine Geoffrey Cox he's trying
to get some final changes to this and I
just think fundamentally that was a big
mistake but look they've done it and we
are where we are but for me there were
three who actually wrote an article I
can't quite remember which ones they
were now but to be honest that's old
news last week's news from my point of
view I just wanted to be free to
participate in this debate at a critical
hour because I'll back the Prime
Minister's deal I hope that Geoffrey
[ __ ] can come back with some changes
that will reassure others so that they
might - but you know if Parliament
cannot accept this deal we have to have
the confidence and the courage as a
country to walk away first and talk
after and the other thing about No Deal
is it doesn't mean No Deal forevermore
it's a bit of a misnomer
No Deal probably in effect means an
informal transition period for nine
months and we already know from all of
our dealings of the European Union that
pretty much across the piece they are
looking for informal arrangements where
there'll be very little change for a
period of nine months
and that gives you a window in which
talks could continue now according to
reports and you gave the Prime Minister
both barrels and a meeting last with
some of her and her of the ministers
last week so what happened to that
meeting what did she say that got you so
riled up well I don't think I did get
riled up I know I saw some of that i was
irate and look I'm not gonna go into the
details of a meeting but pretty much
everything I said in my resignation
letter with the points that I raised I
mean the fundamental question is this if
Parliament takes no deal off the table
and signals to the European Union that
we're too scared as a country to walk
out the door and then demands that the
Prime Minister go cap in hand to
Brussels at the eleventh hour with maybe
just ten days to go to beg for an
extension what happens next the EU will
dictate the terms of that extension they
will come back they may say it has to be
two years they may say there has to be a
very large financial cost to that
extension and what will Parliament do at
that point when it may be at this stage
has three or four days until brexit day
and it's pace are faced with some
impossible demands from the European
Union so I don't think those in
Parliament who sought to frustrate this
process and sought to create an option
to delay brexit have fully thought
through what they're actually doing do
you think Teresa only listens more to
the remainder than her cabinet than she
does the brexit supporting instance no I
don't think that's fair I think the
truth is Teresa Mays had a very
difficult task because from the
beginning she's been undermined by those
in Parliament who refused to respect the
referendum results and there's a large
number of them aiming for a second
referendum trying to restrain this
process but she's also faced a European
Union that's seen weakness seen the lack
of resolve from Parliament sees that
Parliament is trying to frustrate the
process and so has not been in any mood
to negotiate in good faith and the
European Union have deliberately played
games to drag this process out to make
it difficult and so the Prime Minister's
had a very difficult hand I don't
dispute that and I as I said in my
letter she's shown a great deal of
resilience and a great deal of tenacity
but you know what we need from all
political leaders now every
P in Parliament since they've taken
control is the courage to be willing to
walk away